avec vous franck louvrier alors on vous
connaît comme conseiller en
communication pendant plusieurs années
de nicolas sarkozy mais vous êtes aussi
le directeur de publicis events donc
quelqu'un qui est vraiment spécialisé
dans l'histoire des meetings tout de
suite la réaction l'hologramme vous
l'auriez tenté avec nicolas sarkozy
le chapeau chapeau beau je pense que
c'était une très bonne idée
ce que ça lui permet de se démultiplier
alors la méthode est assez classique qui
serait sur skype sauf que maintenant la
technologie permet d'être en hologramme
mais avec l'entreprise fidelio que je
connais il a pu faire cette opération et
je pense que c'est une bonne idée parce
que c'est un candidat qui est plutôt
marginal par rapport aux autres et il a
réussi à apprendre le devant en matière
de communication
là c'est une surprise pour moi franck
louvrier mélenchonistes en termes de
commandes en jeu la casquette uniquement
de communicants mais franchement je
pense que c'est une opération
intéressante et sans doute qu'elle sera
des petits